buonasera a tutti
il maestro mimmo jodice che con il suo
bianco e nero dell'anima ha stregato il
mondo quando gli abbiamo chiesto di
raccontare il suo rione il rione sanità
nel quale è nato e cresciuto e la
fondazione che adesso noi presi e della
fondazione san gennaro lui ha scelto
questa splendida fotografia
demetra demetra e dispensa tritsch e di
grano di papaveri demetra
rappresenta un po per noi questa storia
che racconto il rione sanità di napoli è
un rione magico e ricco di risorse ma è
ricco anche di sofferenze la bellezza
dei suoi tratti la ricchezza dei suoi
gioielli la finezza delle trine lo
rendono particolarissimo e inalterabili
nel tempo sono questi aspetti così come
sono nel tempo perenne i segni profondi
che si leggono sul suo volto
ci sono delle profonde ferite nel
quartiere ora proverò a raccontarvi la
capacità che questo rione a di
affrancarsi dal disagio utilizzando il
bello ed è una storia che di cambiamento
che parte dal basso e punta all'essenza
da un po di tempo alla sanità si è
ripreso a suonare a fare musica a fare
danza fare teatro ea recuperare i beni
storico artistici ci siamo convinti che
il napoli va ricostruita e restaurata
nelle cose e nello spirito
e allora il discorso del recupero della
valorizzazione ci siamo chiesti per noi
del rione sanità non è certamente
una un salotto per anime belle non è un
imperativo costituzionale è qualcosa di
diverso e la chiave per riscoprire un
antico modello di sviluppo umano ed
economico
con queste premesse si è pensato di dare
stabilità a un cammino che proverò a
raccontarvi costituendo una fondazione
nel dicembre scorso per dare sostegno ai
progetti già avviati per dare stabilità
nel tempo e anche auspicabili loro
evoluzioni e abbiamo voluto chiamare
questa fondazione san gennaro c'entra
sembrava un brand si può dire brand
abbastanza interessanti
ormai ci hanno fatto diventare
italianissimi allora i soci fondatori ci
sono sempre in una fondazione questa di
comunità sono al momento 13 vedete tutte
queste sigle questi nomi sono imprese
sono fondazioni e bello e simpatico
notare che ci sono anche due fondazioni
di milano perché non è qualcosa che è
chiuso in quella comunità ma è una
comunità che cerca complici anche fuori
certo i soci più determinanti importanti
sono il rione stesso e la comunità ma è
simpatica questa contaminazione sono
tredici hanno messo idee hanno messo
esperienze competenze e non meno di
centomila euro per dare stabilità e
patrimonio alla fondazione i soci
sostenitori sono e saranno migliaia
tutti quelli che vorranno esserci anche
solo con un centesimo
detto questo prova a descrivere il
quartiere che vi invito a visitare il
rione sanità era una valle cimiteriale
nell'antichità a cucciolata sotto la
collina di capodimonte
poi la città diventata capitale si è
allargata si è ingrandita e ha destinato
quest'area alla nobiltà e alla ricca
borghesia nel 1800 nel decennio francese
la costruzione di un'enorme porte e
decreta l'esclusione di questo pezzo di
città riducendola a un vero e proprio
ghetto
la sanità è una periferia vera e propria
nel pieno centro della città densamente
abitata con i titoli i vicoli che
raccontano storie di emarginazione di
degrado la disoccupazione la
microcriminalità la delinquenza devianza
sono quelle che la cronaca più tratta
del nostro quartiere e nell'immaginario
comune è un luogo da evitare un luogo
non visitato dagli stessi napoletani un
luogo nel quale si possono fare brutti
incontri nell'immaginario ma non è
questo o quantomeno non è soltanto
questo sta incominciando sia la custodia
del passato sia la cooperazione tra
multi oggi sta incominciando a disegnare
quasi una strada profetica una cosa
nuova
da quando la comunità cristiana questa è
una delle chiese più belle che che
gestisco come prede la chiesa di santa
maria della sanità da quando la comunità
cristiana aperto le porte
ai giovani e ha investito in educazione
e soprattutto ha messo a disposizione
dei ragazzi gli spazi e l'immenso
patrimonio storico artistico si è
liberata una vitalità effervescente e
cambiato tutto è incominciato qualcosa
di straordinario e di bello
questi giovani si trovano in un
quartiere che potete trovare arte
bellezza in ogni angolo in ogni palazzo
in ogni catacomba in ogni basilica si
respira ovunque ma voglio sottolineare
che la parte più bella resta in questi
volti in questa in questo tessuto umano
e sociale che ha una particolare
caratteristica è aperto alla creatività
e aperto all'arte
come si fa la crescita di un territorio
noi pensiamo diversamente a qualcuno che
fini e mezzi debbano sempre coincidere
non è possibile utilizzare qualunque
mezzo per raggiungere un fine e se il
fine nella nostra comunità e il fine
della cura del bello e la cultura della
responsabilità del dono se questo è il
fine i mezzi devono essere soltanto
questi è il primo è noto a tutti che la
musica fa bene al cuore e rende migliori
pensati e rione sanità in questi anni
ben due orchestre sinfoniche
con 44 elementi ciascuno vivono
sperimentano un programma di educazione
musicale pubblico diffuso capillare con
l'accesso libero e gratuito da parte di
bambini adolescenti di tutti i ceti
sociali
un altro strumento nel rione sanità la
funzione liberatoria del teatro s'impone
voglio ricordare per chi non è pratico
del rione che il quartiere dove è nato
totò e quindi vedere anche una chiesa
trasformata in un teatro è una gioia e
per me che sono parroco di ben quattro
parrocchie vedere in questi luoghi una
volta abbandonati vedere i ragazzi che
danzano e che fanno teatro è davvero una
gioia vi ricordo che ireneo di lione
diceva che la gloria di dio è questa è
l'uomo vivente
è strano e curioso e mi piace
raccontarlo alla sanità i nostri bambini
hanno anche scoperto una centinaia di
loro hanno scoperto il mare sembra una
barzelletta napoli e così il mare è
precluso ai poveri e 100 bambini hanno
fatto corsi di vela sono state
contaminazioni straordinarie
sperimentazioni impensabili immaginate
che uno di questi ragazzi adesso è
campione regionale
quello che manca ai miei bambini diceva
don lorenzo milani è il dominio sulla
parola
lui aveva compreso come importante
scindere l'ignoranza dalla povertà e
come era vero per don lorenzo milani lo
è tanto più oggi per noi e per i nostri
poveri alla sanità in ben due case
canoniche noi accogliamo ragazzi per
dare loro la possibilità di imparare a
dominare la parola altrui e la parola
propria che altro si fa ecco da parte un
po più interessante a un certo punto
è nata l'idea di prendere in mano in
maniera vera i beni storico artistici
dal 2009 il pontificio consiglio della
cultura affidato al territorio la
gestione delle catacombe di napoli
lì tutto si è accelerato tutto è
incominciato a correre che è successo i
ragazzi del quartiere costituiti in
cooperativa oggi ne sono 15 che
gestiscono queste splendide catacombe
con contratto a tempo indeterminato
hanno presi in carica la cura delle
basiliche delle catacombe
vedete facilmente che in questi anni
proprio in questi anni difficili hanno
avuto un aumento di incremento del 300
per cento le previsioni sono ancora più
rose e quindi si prevedono altre
assunzioni però i ragazzi non si sono
fermati soltanto all'uso allo
sfruttamento alla fruizione del bene che
è servito sia rompere il ghetto perché
sono venute 60mila persone quindi il
ghetto è diventato meno ghetto ma si
sono preoccupati anche nella
conservazione una cosa molto
interessante e intelligente quindi hanno
avviato un processo di recupero
innovativo non soltanto perché hanno
usato gli strumenti tecnologici
innovativi ma perché attento ai
diversamente abili
pensate che le catacombe di napoli sono
le uniche accessibile a tutti
c'era poi da fare manutenzione ordinaria
e straordinaria
il patrimonio erano queste tante chiese
queste più catacombe questi giardini
queste case canoniche da me unico prete
con tante case e senza mogli difficili
da usare quindi tutto questo
tutto questo patrimonio
era da gestire e quindi l'ordinaria e la
straordinaria manutenzione si è pensato
di affidarla ad altri giovani nel rione
questi sono costituiti in cooperativa di
tipo b è solo una quindicina
qualcuno si chiederà ma perché tutte ste
cooperative
e semplice noi siamo del sud c funziona
prima il cuore poi la testa noi prima di
fare cooperazione abbiamo bisogno di
sentirci fratelli e le piccole
cooperative ci aiutano a sentirci a casa
a sentirci fratelli e ci aiutano anche a
inserire meglio quelli che normalmente
sono i più fragili quelli che vengono
esclusi dal mercato del lavoro da me
sono soprattutto i ragazzi che hanno i
circuiti che hanno vissuto esperienze in
circuiti penali e pensiamo siamo
convinti che la pietra scartata dai
costruttori è diventata testata d'angolo
siamo convinti che i nostri poveri
devono sempre più diventare pietra
angolare dello stesso sistema del
welfare che li sostiene
le ricadute sono state parecchie
innumerevoli pensate che si è avuto un
aumento della del restauro nella zona un
aumento dell'artigianato i servizi della
ristorazione
pensate nei soci fondatori
c'è un gruppo legato al contratto di
rete che sono gli imprenditori del
quartiere i quali hanno incominciato a
comprendere insieme alle parrocchie
insieme al no profit sono la parte più
interessante di questa fondazione di
comunità
ancora tra le bizzarre cooperative
potete incontrare uno studio di
registrazione
moderno potete incontrare delle mamme
che cerca di offrire catering potreste
incontrare un'accoglienza coccolata tra
poco in tre strutture recettive si sta
capendo a rione sanità che ci sono le
risorse
il presidente mm udc dice sempre che sia
avviato un fenomeno culturale che
difficilmente potrà essere fermato
a qualcuno piacciono i numeri a meno
tanto prova a spiegarli sono stati in
questi anni illuminati
10620 metri quadrati di patrimonio sono
stati restaurati 632 metri quadrati di
patrimonio e resi fruibili
11450 metri quadrati di opere d'arte
chiuse cioè locali case chiese basiliche
catacombe eccetera più di 100 partner e
più di 100 dipendenti direttamente e
indirettamente
200 mila sono i visitatori in questi
anni che hanno rotto la marginalità del
quartiere e hanno fatto un po i conti
ragazzi ci sono 4 milioni di euro che
sono serviti al recupero al restauro e
agli start up di queste piccole imprese
penso poco e tutto rigorosamente
raccolto tra privati tra fondazioni di
pubblico non c'è ancora nulla di fatto
al rione sanità sono un po più lenti né
ci arriveranno anche loro
ancora la cultura è quello che noi
cerchiamo di di vivere in questo rione
vi dicevo la cultura del bello la
cultura della responsabilità della
gratuita sono questi gli obiettivi della
fondazione e la fondazione partecipa a
un bando della fondazione con il sud che
prevede il raddoppio delle risorse
raccolte nei prossimi anni noi speriamo
di riuscire almeno a recuperare due
milioni e mezzo che col sistema del
raddoppio che offre la fondazione con il
sud ce lo porterà a 5 milioni noi a
rione sanità diciamo spesso che il
umanesimo o diventa umanità o muore un
umanesimo che diventa umanità e bellezza
una bellezza come diceva per paolo
pasolini che si vede perché viva e del
reale ma per vedere la bellezza diceva
lo stesso pasolini c'è bisogno di occhi
aperti gli occhi curiosi di occhi che
credono che accada qualcosa di occhi che
credono che esiste il bello e allora
adesso che mi sono stancato pure di
parlare non abituato come sono a parlare
da noi si vive più per
trasmissioni di immagini di suoni e non
tanto di parole quindi vorrei lasciarvi
con un piccolo video nel quale potete
fare un'esperienza sensuale del rione
sanità utilizzare anche altri sensi ma
con gli occhi aperti potete vedere i
vicoli del mio partire nei quali scorre
il veleno e scorre anche il vitale
ossigeno e potete incontrare in ogni
vicolo un punto esclamativo quello che
una volta si chiamava il punto
ammirativo quello che sancisce nella
scrittura lo stupore la meraviglia
dell'incontro con la bellezza buona
visione e grazie
nunzia sta di casa in un basso e per lei
quella il corridoio
per la signora carmela quando si
affaccia al balcone del primo piano
diventa un teatro
berlino che in quella vera non ci va più
è la scuola
ciccio se lo deve fare tutto impennando
malamente con lesse h preparato se no
non è qui
per stasera mazzata un fronte a ogni
volta che deve portare le casse d'acqua
sopra dalla signora cosa
per jenny luca ciro susa e maria
erogante vallone
pure per la signora maurina in cambio
valuta ma se si vuole fare una mezz'ora
di sonno lo deve ad attuare col secchio
fino a quando il creato non se ne vanno
a casa amore
con murray bambini dell'orchestra hanno
imparato a farlo risuonare come uno
strumento musica
per don antonio s'è fatto vecchio elias
team
soprattutto quando passeggio disgraziati
ciccio
per nel uccio faccio festa è meglio che
la in mezzo non si fa vedere
per enzo sono gli ultimi 100 metri prima
di arrivare da gesù mentre gli fa si
sente sempre il cuore che gli sbatte
forte detto lui dice che per la salita
per titti la mena antonietta e la
veranda dove si prende il cristo
d'estate
lucia che lì si andava da quando lavora
alle catacombe dallo racconta in tre
lingue
per marianna e francesca e la passerella
del sabato pomeriggio
per peppe che si deve fare tre anni è
stato un ufficio
lì è dove alessandro ha imparato a
parlare napoletana e dove gaetano
imparato l'italiano d'alessandro
per molti un senso unico a salire che
quando in estate verso le tre e mezza ci
va il sole diventa uno specchio dorate
non sia più
è il piccolo
è per noi anche questo